ALONSO VERA: Thank you.
OK so to start.
When Terry asked
me to present this,
he asked me almost
right away for a title.
So I made one up in
about two seconds.
And then later, I
realized I didn't like it
because as I was actually
preparing slides for this,
I realized that it's
a false dichotomy.
I mean, replacing humans
or working with them--
because sometimes you do
want to replace humans.
So I realize that's not
really the question.
So I made a second slide
which I like better.
OK.
So really, the talk is
about human-autonomy
teaming for complex,
non-deterministic activities.
So, you know, there
will be many instances
where autonomy will likely
work independent of humans.
And really this whole
talk is about how do we
know and begin to understand the
context in which you actually
want to keep humans
as part of a system?
And then how do you do that?
And I'm going to talk
a little bit about some
of the things we do at NASA.
But in some ways it's
largely a set of thoughts
that I put together from work
that NASA is doing broadly
in aeronautics and space.
And especially on
the aeronautics side,
NASA's gone through a fairly
significant transformation
to focus more on autonomy.
And this has become
a big debate.
So do you look at
autonomy in the way
that we had for really
a couple of decades.
I don't know if you're familiar
with-- you probably aren't.
The Department of
Defense for a long time
thought of this as
levels of autonomy.
And it was a
professor at MIT, Tom
Sheridan, who came up with this
concept of levels of autonomy.
And the idea was
that our technology
would develop from
one where you've
got humans doing
everything to now
human is assisted a
little bit or informed
a little bit by autonomy.
An increasing role of autonomy
until you have autonomy
doing everything, right?
And no human anymore.
And that was this idea
levels of autonomy.
And you were trying to
understand areas of application
in terms of where are
we, what level are we at,
and where were we going to?
And Department of Defense did
a study about 10 years ago--
or funded a study
about 10 years ago,
which said that's probably
not the way things are going.
And so the new idea
is cognitive echelons.
And cognitive echelons-- and
I'll talk about this more.
And in fact, I
think the whole talk
is sort of about this-- is the
idea that really what you're
looking at is for any
given type of activity,
what is the cognitive
demand of that activity?
And what type of cognitive
demand does it have?
And that tells you for that type
of activity, how much autonomy
and how much human you need.
And with the idea
that some of that
is going to stay going
forward, that balance
is going to stay about the
same going forward, even
as autonomy increases, OK?
And so I see it as my
goal to try and convince
you a little bit of that idea.
The core idea being that
although what we're seeing
is that robotic and human
interfaces are progressing
quickly, AI not so much.
So that's one theme
But even if that weren't true.
So let's say AI was
progressing a lot faster.
The second point--
or maybe probably
the core point of the talk
is that human intelligence
and the way that humans
understand things and process
things is, at the
moment, fundamentally
different than the way we're
doing it computationally.
And that shouldn't be
a surprise to anybody,
but I'll go through
that a little bit.
And unless things take a big
turn sometime in the future,
where either our machine
intelligence becomes
effectively omniscient
and can think in every way
or we really start
figuring out how
to simulate human intelligence,
human intelligence by itself
will remain unique and have
certain unique values that
are probably going to be true
for the next 50 to 100 years,
possibly longer.
So that's the argument
I want to make.
And then, finally, the
practical outcome of this
is that if you don't
design intelligent systems,
increasingly autonomous
systems, to interact with humans
because your humans are going
to stay part of the system,
because some of the intelligence
is going to stay in your human.
If you don't design
those systems
to interact with humans, your
costs go up rather than down.
So let me start with this.
Basically I think everybody
here is well familiar with this.
But you look the last
four years in the news.
Like almost weekly, there's
something about AI in the news.
And so from things
like-- just jumping
to the second big bullet
here, Stephen Hawking
and Bill Gates and
Elon Musk all warning
about the dangers of AI.
So you talk to the public
and they say, oh, what's
really happening out there?
Is this dangerous?
And so part of my argument
is, probably not really.
So some of my view
is that that's not
really quite correct.
Although there are
certain dangers, but--
Now, what we're seeing
really at its core
is four things that are driving
machine intelligence forward.
So, big data.
And big data's been
a fundamental change
in terms of getting
behavior that
seems more intelligent to us.
Deep learning, which is
big data plus neural nets.
Networked operations and
cyber-physical systems--
that begins to
really change-- it
moves intelligence out
to the periphery in a way
that that decentralization
creates a lot more adaptivity.
And then Moore's law, which
continues reasonably unabated.
And so you take
those in combination.
And really, what we've seen
over the last 5 to 10 years
is a significant surge in
our machine intelligence
capabilities.
And it's introduced to
us in our daily life.
So you search for
images in Google.
And it'll say, you want more
images that look like this.
And it kinda comes up
with a lot of images
that look like-- in a
sensible way to us humans--
it'll look like the
ones you've searched.
I could go through
a lot of examples
So also self-driving
cars, robotic operations,
like in the factories like
Amazon or Tesla-Toyota.
Then Big Blue, Watson,
Poker Bot-- those
have all been fairly recent.
Just earlier this year, Google
DeepMind beats a human at Go.
And February, there
was a piece in the news
about the first artificial
intelligence investment
software in Wallstreet.
I haven't heard if it's
done well or poorly.
Actually, I should have
done that piece of research
before coming, to
see whether it made
any money on its investments.
Because I know my
16-year-old daughter
is in the investment club.
And that by itself does
not mean you're doing well.
So let me give you
an example, here.
And this example is really sort
of at the heart of, I think,
what I'm going to argue.
When the Navy needs
a new ship or just
like when the Air
Force needs a new ship,
there's a whole process.
And you take it to Congress.
And you say, we need
a new ship to do.
X and its requirements based.
So they took this
to Congress and said
we need to reduce manpower.
So we need a ship that can be
sailed by a lot fewer sailors.
And so this is
many years of work.
It goes and finally gets
approved by Congress
and goes through.
And the goal was
to build a ship--
and this is called the littoral
combat ship-- that would
be operated by 45 sailors.
And in the end,
what happened was
this was delivered around 2012.
And it wasn't operable
by 45 sailors.
It was operable by 60 sailors.
And that- if you are in
the field of human systems
integration-- that's not so bad.
To be off by 25% is
actually a pretty good.
Often these things are off
by an order of magnitude.
But that wasn't
the real problem.
So the real problem is
that on any given ship--
let's say you have 400
people-- most of the sailors
are actually doing
low skilled tasks.
So sailors are-- it's
a pyramid, right?
They go from E1 to E10.
And you get to the
E5s-- E5s are very rare.
Any given ship has just a
handful of E5s and above.
So the bottom of the
pyramid, the E1s, the E2s,
there's are the bulk of
the people on a boat.
Turns out this thing,
the littoral combat ship,
was saleable by 60
E5s and above, only.
So it caused all
sorts of problems.
And the reason it
required E5s was it
was really hard to
manage the systems.
You needed to have a lot of
training, a lot of skills.
You needed to be fairly
intelligent to be
able to do it.
And so this was a
bit of a disaster.
Turns out that on top of it,
the conditions on the ship
were really miserable,
because it was built for 45
and you're putting 60.
So they actually
literally put 45 beds,
the kitchen was for 45 people.
Everything was for 45 and
you're putting 60 on it.
So they've had a lot of
their upper grade sailors
leave after one tour in the
Navy because this is very bad.
Anyway, there was this guy,
Naval, postgraduate school here
in Monterey who came
and told us this story.
And I spent some time with him
just trying to understand--
and I won't go
into too much more
detail about what went wrong.
But the most interesting part
of this is that if you ask,
did the companies that
delivered the littoral combat
ship fail to do what they
promised they would do?
The answer was, no.
They delivered a
largely autonomous ship.
It's just that they
didn't worry about how
the 45 sailors, those
remaining roles,
would interact
with that autonomy.
And so the cost went up.
And you needed 60
people instead of 45.
But on top of it,
like the real cost
was, again, the fact that all
the sailors had to be E5s.
And there's a
little white paper,
and you can look this up.
It's great.
It's like a three or four page
white paper by Blackhurst.
It's Jack Blackhurst, Sharon
Gresham, and Morley Stone.
They're at Air Force
Research Labs in Dayton.
And It's called "The
Autonomy Paradox."
And they basically
say, look, you
take the sum lessons of
the Department of Defense--
so very broad-- and every
time you invest in autonomy,
your costs increase.
And it's not because the economy
didn't do what it promised,
it is because you didn't
understand how it was going
to change the human roles.
And in the end, you had
to put more humans on it
than was originally planned.
So your costs actually increase.
And so for example, at NASA,
we're very aware of this,
So it takes more people to fly
an unmanned aerial system--
like say a drone-- than
it does to pilot a plane.
It's like nine people to fly a
drone versus a couple of people
to fly a plane.
So this is the case today.
Now you know, we might
say this might change.
But this is the understanding.
So there's one lesson
from this, at least,
that I want to start
out with, which
is that as machine intelligence
advances in a system,
you need to worry more about the
interfaces with humans rather
than less.
So the simpler
system, the less you
have to worry about
the interfaces.
So systems that do fairly
straightforward things,
like your microwave, it
doesn't have to be that hard.
Things that have increasingly
complex relationships and tasks
that we do together,
like other humans--
We humans have very
complex systems
to interact with one another.
Anyway so that's going
to be a recurring theme.
I wanna give one other-- given
that this is a NASA talk,
this is from our own
experience at NASA.
So you can't see
the arrow very well,
but there is an arrow here that
shows a temporal progression.
So in 2003, we started working
on the Mars Exploration Rovers
Mission.
And it was a small
human-computer interaction
group.
And we were asked to contribute
to a number of tools that
were being developed to
the Mars Exploration Rovers
Mission, which was being
run out of JPL down in LA.
And it was great.
It was a great experience.
A lot of us has
just come to NASA.
It was very interesting.
The whole mission
was run on Mars time.
So they arranged apartments
for us that were blacked out.
Food trucks would
show up on Mars time.
So it was 40 minutes off a day.
So every day, it'd
be another-- so you'd
get to work at
9:40, then at 10:20
then at 11 o'clock every day.
It was very strange to do
it for a number of weeks.
Because it's worse
than being on ships,
because you can't even
develop a regular schedule.
But that's what we were doing.
I mean there were things like we
were issued Mars time watches.
And at one point,
I was in a store.
And I was wearing
my Mars time watch
on one and my regular
watch on the other.
And someone said, why are
you wearing two watches?
And I said, I'm working
on a Mars mission.
And, she was like, security
to the front desk, please.
So there was a lot
of just oddness
of trying to have your
daily life while we
were working on that mission.
But one of the
things that happened
was that we got brought in
to work on a planning system.
So it turned out that
that mission was really
the first mission
where NASA decided
to do real time planning,
or near real time planning.
So in general,
what NASA does is,
if you're going to send
a mission to Mercury,
you plan out that mission.
Because you pretty much
understand the orbital dynamics
and all that.
So you're going to send it,
it's going to go around Mercury.
So you can plan that
mission down to the minute.
And that's what we do.
And then we're going
to take this picture,
we're going to do that.
And that's planned to a
high level of resolution
a year before the
mission even launches.
This mission was
the first one where
the hope was that if both
rovers landed safely,
that you would actually be
getting science data back
every day.
So you had these science
teams, about 100 scientists--
geologists, atmospheric
scientists, dust scientists.
And they would get together
and look at all the data
that was coming
back and every day
generate a new set of
activities to be radiated up
to those rovers.
And the number of activities
that were sent up to the rover
was about 500 to 600 a day.
And those were highly
inter-constrained.
So they were all
in interdependent.
Take this picture
before this one.
Take this one as close
to noon as possible.
Don't take this one if you
haven't taken the other ones.
So there were about
say 500, 600 things
to do sending up to the
rover and close to a thousand
constraints every day.
And that was a big plan.
And then a little
engineering team
had to come up with
a plan like that
that wasn't going to break
the rover, that wasn't going
to breach like all the
power rules for the day, all
these things-- and do it in a
matter of a couple of hours.
And so that hadn't been done.
So the first thing
that Ames did was
suggest, look, what we need
here is an intelligent planning
system.
And so they took the existing
Jet Propulsion Lab planning
system-- which was called
APGEN, Activity Plan Generator--
and put a backend that basically
took all the inputs, all
the activities, all the
constraints, and optimized it
and did some intelligent
things in terms of some cases
with some flexibility
of the constraints,
and then gave you a plan.
And at that time, it was
bit of a break through.
It was a real mission
using machine intelligence.
Within a very short
amount of time,
the engineers at
Jet Propulsion Lab
said, no, this is
completely unacceptable.
They called the
system "the blender."
Because it would put your
activities here and there.
And then it would optimize it.
And you had no way
to validate it.
You had no way to find
where it had put things.
And so they came back to
us and they said, OK, we
need to, for example, I need
to be able to pin activities.
And so that's when they came to
the Human-Computer Interaction
Group.
And they said, could
you design an interface
so that we can pin activities?
And we said, yeah--
little drop down menu,
you select something,
you pin it.
And then I remember asking one
of the people on the Ames side
who was responsible
and I said, look,
do you want it so
that I, as the user,
can move things around
after I've pinned them?
And the person said, well, no.
You just pinned it.
So why would you be able
to move things around?
And I said, well, I didn't
pin it so I can't move it.
I pinned so the stupid
system can't move it.
That's their point, right?
So you had all these, who's
in charge, kind of questions.
Anyway, long story short-- or
long story longer, really-- we
did some adaptation to that
one, developed a couple
of other tools around planning.
That ended up getting expanded
into the Phoenix Science
Interface, which was the 2007
Polar Lander on Mars, which
was another successful mission.
We were asked, what if we
tried to make the engineers do
the plan-- sorry, the scientists
do the plan rather than
the engineers?
Before that, only the
engineers, the Rover engineers,
did the planning.
We said, well, maybe
you can abstract away
some of the Rover stuff.
And that turned out to work.
And that was all Human-Computer
Interaction work.
As we went through from
the Mars Exploration Rovers
to the Phoenix Lander to
Mars Science Laboratory,
which is the big Rover
that's on Mars now, and then
Space Station, LADEE,
a different mission.
And now, we're doing
these analog missions.
NEEMO is the
underwater lab that's
off of Key Largo where
astronauts go and [INAUDIBLE].
So this is like the-- we've
moved to doing it on pads
so that-- And we're looking
now at crew self scheduling.
And that's our big thing, now.
So the tool is now being
used on Space Station
since last summer for astronauts
to schedule their own time.
The point of this is
that the transition
was from an early design where
we said an intelligent system
that just does planning for
you-- which was basically
rejected by the
mission-- to eventually
an evolution to over a decade
of a lot of work to making it
so that the users-- and
increasingly non-expert users--
can interact with
the complex planning
systems and complex plans
to really enable the human
to do a much more complex task
very quickly than they would
have before, but without,
in a sense, kind of doing it
for them in a way that humans
tend to find frustrating.
So this has been one
of our big experiences
over the last
decade in this area.
And this could be a talk
by itself, but it's not.
So that's the
argument, that we're
going in a direction
of supporting humans.
And I want to make
a distinction here.
We're making progress, I
think, in supporting humans
interacting with
systems, but more so
in certain areas than others.
So here, you look at robots.
So this is a picture
from the Tesla facility.
And these are,
really, caged robots.
So last year at the
Honda facility--
at a Honda facility
in Japan, a worker
was killed by one of
the robots, got crushed.
It wasn't the robot's
fault. That robot
had no sensors built into it
to detect a human in its space.
I mean a human went
in, got crushed.
So they're caged because they're
blind to the world around them.
They're designed that way.
And they're designed that way
because it costs more money,
it's more complex to make
them so that they interact.
And then you have like
these domesticated robots,
like the Roomba.
And this is from El
Camino hospital, here.
If you've been there
recently, there
are these little
boxes that go around
and they're aware of you,
they'll follow you-- well
they won't follow you.
But if you're walking and
it walking there behind you,
they won't run you over.
They'll wait.
They're a little
slow and clumsy.
But they're are
little robots that
are going around the hospital.
And the point here is
that we have caged robots,
and we have domesticated
robots when they
have to interact with humans.
And I'll talk about
this in a second.
But for autonomy, in some ways--
I think one of my key points
is that we're still really
talking about caged autonomy.
We tend to think of
autonomy in the sense
of replacing humans rather
than working with them,
assisting them, and really
working on those interfaces.
And that's how we end
up with these problems
like the littoral combat ship.
This is a robot that you're
probably familiar with.
There's a version of
it on Space Station.
It's called Robonaut.
And what's interesting
about it is
that it is designed to
physically interact with humans
in a very constrained
environment.
So if it's moving its
arm and you bump into it,
it will withdraw its arm.
So it's very
sensitive to-- So it
is the opposite of a machine
that would crush somebody
because it has no sensors.
The thing has
sensors all over it
to make sure that if
somebody nudges it,
it pulls back-- all that stuff.
But again, the
important thing is
that that's where we have to
go with our autonomy work.
How do we make it so that for
real, complex, more cognitive
kind of systems, rather
than robotic systems,
we're making progress in
terms of teaming with humans.
I want to give just
a couple of examples
of the kinds of problems
that I think characterize
the areas where humans will
remain a key part of things.
So there was a story in
Bloomberg about a year or two
ago when I actually contacted
Toyota and talked to them
a little bit about this.
But they basically reported that
they were replacing humans--
sorry, replacing robots
on the manufacturing
floor with humans.
So taking robots off
the production line
and putting humans in.
And when asked why, they
said, well, basically, there's
a long tradition in
Japan of mastery,
sort of going back
to the samurai,
you how to make your own sword.
But then in the end, they
said that the bottom line
is that when you put a robot on
something, it stops improving.
And not only does
it stop improving,
nobody knows how to improve it.
So in fact, Terry and I,
just a couple weeks ago,
were at a car
manufacturing facility.
And we talked to
the people there.
And they said no, the processes
are improving all the time,
like all the time.
I was actually surprised.
They said at any
given point in time
they're working 30 or
40 process improvements
at any given station.
Because the humans are like,
yeah if we put this here,
it will be a little better.
And it's just a
constant improvement.
And so Toyota is finding
that for everywhere
where you've got a machine,
there's no more improvement.
So that's one area.
Rio Tinto is one of the big
mining companies in the world.
It's Australia based.
And they have a mine that is
almost entirely autonomous.
So the trucks drive themselves,
the drills, everything.
There are little drones
that go around and monitor.
And so they have
a control center
from which they watch things.
But similarly, they came, at
some point, to us and said,
like look-- Because
I said, well, look.
Sounds like you've
solved your problem.
Why are you coming
to talk to us?
You've got your mine
running without people,
so you presumably saved the
money that you wanted to save.
And they said,
no, the problem is
we need to put some
people back in.
Then that was interesting.
We said, like for what?
Well, sometimes you need
expert geologists in there
to see whether you're going
to drill this way or that way.
Because you still are nowhere
near replacing, say, an expert
geologist in terms
of actually being
able to physically look
at a space and say,
this is the way to go.
Or mines are constantly changing
and where the trucks drive.
So all of the
optimization, the using
of the space, all of that,
they needed humans in there.
But they're having trouble
putting humans back in,
because the whole thing was
designed to have no humans.
So, again, similar example.
Self-driving cars.
I said this earlier.
So one thing about
driving is driving
is a largely
low-cognitive demand task.
So the reason that
humans-- that it's
hard for us in a lot of
instances to drive, especially
say on highways when
it's long and boring,
is because it demands
attention, but is not
at all cognitively engaging.
So you have to stay
paying attention.
It's like life guarding.
I remember I life
guarded in the summer.
It was like
mindnumbingly boring.
So you have to
develop little things,
like you count the number
of little kids or whatever.
So there are these
tasks where you
have to stay paying attention.
But they're not engaging.
So the fact that
we're making progress,
as Google is and
other companies are
in the area of
self-driving cars,
is indicative of remarkable
progress in robotics,
but not necessarily yet in the
high cognitive demand tasks
that I'm trying to capture,
here, with for example talking
about the optimization and in
factories and things like that,
where if you put a robot
in, you'll lose something.
And I mean, one thing
that remains to be seen
and-- I don't know.
We don't know the way it's
going to turn out, yet.
But as we try and get
closer to human performance.
And human performance
in self-driving cars
isn't that great.
I mean we all know in the
order of 40,000 people
die every year on the roads.
But when you look at the
number of hours driven-- which
a remarkably small number.
So it's in the order of 1
every 200,000 to 300,000 miles
for regular people that we
have a serious accident--
every 10, 15, 20 years-- and
most of us, knock on wood,
never.
And so the last 5% challenge--
which you always know,
like the beginning is easy.
And as you get to
the end, you're
squeezing out all the little
edge cases-- that's what hard.
And that's what we're
going to bump into here.
And there's a bit of a question.
I tend to think that it
may be a little hard as we
get to the last
5% to squeeze out
that performance without
actually understanding
the world.
And that's the
thing with humans.
We actually understand
the world in certain ways
rather than, kind of just
have pattern recognition
and association between things.
And part of the problem is we
don't necessarily understand
that well how humans do it.
That's the whole problem
of consciousness,
and what does it mean to be
self-aware, and all that.
And what does it
mean for me to be,
here I am, standing
in front of you guys.
I'm aware of all this stuff.
We don't understand
it all that well.
But we know that it
functions in a way that
allows us to understand
the world in certain ways,
causally, be able
to predict things,
anticipate things, to learn
things faster than others.
And that's what I'll
go into a little bit.
And so I'll leave it at that.
I'm not going to
come back to this.
But the idea that at some
point, to really kind of
squeeze out the last
5% of performance,
to get up to where humans are--
even though humans aren't that
good at driving--
it may take more
of an understanding of
the world than we're
moving toward right now.
So here's a view of
where we are right now.
And this isn't my slide.
This is from Missy
Cummings at Georgia Tech.
She says, look, right now,
computers can do skills
and think of skills
as routine activities.
Like in driving, you
might think of it
as being able to effect
smooth turns and the braking.
And then there are rules like,
I know what I do at stop signs.
And I know what I
do at red lights.
And I know what I do at four way
stop signs versus two way stop
signs, and all that.
And then you have
knowledge, which is really
a higher level of integration.
So for example, I have
knowledge of this area
of Mountain View and Los Altos
and this part of the Bay Area.
Sometimes you go for work to
a new city, you rent a car,
you have no knowledge.
It's a little bit harder.
You still have your
driving skills,
your still have your rules.
But you don't know the road.
Google Maps has
really transformed.
You know that pretty
well, so you don't even
have to have that knowledge
that much anymore.
And then there's kind
of the expertise.
What if I run into real
issues, into problems?
So this is where we are in 2015.
And here's a view of where,
I think, a lot of people
think we're going
to be in 2035-- 2035
being a somewhat random date.
But 20 years away.
Humans are very good
at overestimating
what we can do in five years
and very good at underestimating
what we can do in 50.
But that's why we chose 20.
It's not 50.
But I think it's
generally agreed
that you're going to make
progress toward getting
more knowledge in here.
But then humans are
still probably going
to be doing your expertise part.
And so things like
driving, you're
going to be able to make
a lot of progress on.
And I've got up here it's
air traffic management.
So managing air
traffic in the US
is-- this is obviously
from our domain--
it's a complex,
non-deterministic problem
with a lot of parts and
where the rules do not
cover the full space
of possible outcomes.
And so that might be
maybe the kind of problem
that, in the end, you
still need some humans in.
And then it all becomes
about worrying about how
does the human stay engaged?
How does the human get
expertise in that area
if the machines are doing a
lot of the low level stuff.
I'm gonna switch gears
for a second here.
I just want to talk a
little bit about humans.
And you're probably
all familiar with this.
But there's an
interesting aspect
of humans and other animals.
17th century philosophers
were concerned with
are humans tabula
rasa, like blank slate.
Are we born blank slate?
You can learn anything.
Or are we born, in a
sense, preprogramed?
So now there's like
very, very clear data
that we're very preprogramed.
So like mountain goats
are born on cliffs.
And the fact that they survive
as a species suggests they're
pretty much programmed
in a very different way
than other animals to
not fall off that cliff.
So this is like a
day-old mountain
goat standing on its mother's
back at the edge of a cliff.
And so Cornell there was work
done in the 50s and 60s-- Oh,
and things like this.
This is something
called the visual cliff.
It's a box.
And then you basically have
a 90 degree angle and then
a piece of Plexiglas.
And they did it with
little mountain goats.
And a mountain goat will
not go near that edge.
Whereas babies, human babies,
if the mother says, come,
baby is like, OK.
So different animals were
programmed in different ways.
And there's certainly a lot
of qualitative understanding
of this and some beginning
of like real scientific
understanding of it,
although still rough.
Another good example that
I like is here on the left.
So think about a hawk
hunting and flying at 200,
250 feet, sees a mouse,
comes down at about 40,
50 miles an hour.
There's wind.
The mouse is running around
trying not to get caught.
And this thing comes
an inch from the ground
and catches the
mouse often enough
that they also
survive as a species--
all with a brain this big.
So the insight that
the Gibsons had--
and it was a married couple at
Cornell, JJ and Jackie GIbson--
was that none of this
is computational.
The hawk isn't coming down and
thinking hard about, turn left.
Two degrees starboard.
Nothing like that.
It was all like flow lines
that pretty much go directly
out to the muscles in the wings.
And so the whole nervous system
is kind of wired in a way
to respond physically
to the environment.
And I won't go into this.
It was this moving room
experiment that was very--
So they did all
these experiments
on humans and animals at
Cornell to just understand
how it is that we are
physically tied to our world,
and I mean that basically the
same thing is true of humans.
You take humans and you
the lines of a room.
if that room moves,
the baby falls over.
The thing with humans is--
and it's so easy for us
to not pay attention to this.
Because in some ways
the fact that we
have a computational engine
as powerful as we do,
each one of them
in our own heads,
makes us just kind
of trivialize it.
And especially as you interact
with other people and you go,
you don't seem that smart.
But each brain has
about 80 billion neurons
with about a trillion
connections, each firing
about five times a second.
And it's a completely
dynamic system.
So literally, there's
been about 40 years
of work to try and understand
even the simplest neural
systems.
So there's been a lot
of work on the lobster.
And the reason people
work on lobsters
is because the axons that
connect the neurons are
almost a millimeter thick.
So it's just these
big, thick axons.
So you can stick electrodes in
them and say, OK, it's firing.
It's not firing.
The whole swimming of a lobster
tail is about 18 neurons.
40 years of work
still has not actually
managed to untangle how
those 18 neurons do it.
18 neurons, not 80 billion.
And then an ant has about
100,000-- like a lot less.
But we still don't even have
artificial ants, nothing
even close that is that
autonomous, independent.
So part of my point here
is although-- again,
because we all have
our brains, we kind of
take them for granted.
But it is a remarkable
computational machine.
And-- going back to
the slide before-- it
is a computational
machine that is very
tied to our human-- sorry to
our physical world environment
as it is.
Now we know certain
things about it.
So the way humans tend
to think is in a--
And, again, a lot of
this stuff is still
understood more qualitatively
than quantitatively,
in part because of the example
I just gave of the lobster tail.
The problem with understanding
how the brain works is not
so much the morphology of the
brain or what happens where.
It's really math.
The math does not exist today to
even understand the 18 neurons
and how they're
working dynamically
to produce the swimming.
So it's going to be a long
time until the brain is fully
understood.
And a lot of money goes into it.
But we know that humans
tend to work by induction
rather than deduction.
So you tend to see
one or two examples
and then expand to, OK, I've
got myself a little theory.
And then maybe you
test it a little.
Our concepts are like that.
Our concepts are, if I
have a concept of a dog,
it's not because I've seen
every dog in the world or even
a million dogs.
I've seen a few dogs
and I expand from that.
And think about how
opposite that is of the way
that our machine learning
is doing it right now,
where you basically are
doing pattern recognition
over a very large set.
And eventually, you
induce something.
As children, by the time you
get to be five, six years old,
you know about 25,000 words.
And you're learning in the
order of 10 to 20 words a day,
all day typically with
one exposure-- bicycle.
Dog.
Hot.
Love.
Right?
You know-- Hot.
Ooh, hot.
Kids get it right away.
And kids is us--
we were all kids.
That's the way
this brain is made.
With all of that come
a set of problems.
And we all understand
human error.
There's been a lot of work on
kind of the human fallacies.
The fact that we pay
too much attention
to certain kinds of information.
That's just the flip side of
the coin of the kind of learning
machines that we are.
We are a certain kind
of learning machine.
And that's my main point.
We're not a general
information processing machine.
We're an information
processing machine that
works in a very causal way.
We build up expertise
in certain areas
and can problem
solve in ways that
are very different than you
get out of, effectively, data
association and
pattern matching.
To give you an example, last
year we had a talk on this.
Mercedes-benz was there.
And nobody had to do any NDAs.
Actually, I've already
seen this on the web.
They did something clever.
They said, look, humans
also use flowlines.
So as I walk here, I'm
not thinking about OK,
am I doing one foot
in front of the other?
My brain is using this
line and that line
to tell me that
I'm still upright
and walking in the
same direction.
They said what if
we do that and here,
we put little lines,
dots that are moving.
And instead of using
it to tell the person
live, yes, you're still upright.
And you'll walk in the
direction you think.
It will anticipate
things a little.
So I'm driving.
And these flowlines
will three, four seconds
before my car turns will tell me
that the car is going to turn.
The beauty of it is it's
not using central attention.
So central attention is one
of the most constrained things
that we humans have.
We have one attention channel.
There's been a lot
of research on this.
And most of the data
points out the fact
that really you
can't pay attention
to two things at once.
You can switch back and
forth pretty quickly,
one, two things.
Three things if
you get good at it.
But mostly you've got
one central channel.
And they've been testing
this, and it works.
So this is at a low level,
what we're talking about,
about intelligent systems
communicating with humans.
How do you think about building
it in so you're not even
taxing humans?
And then in this way then
you start thinking of a car
almost more like a horse.
I mean the horse is doing
some of its own things
and it's communicating
it to-- And this, again,
came from them.
They want cars to be more
like domesticated animals.
On the NASA side, in a lot
of the areas that matter,
we don't have big data.
We have-- it's a little
joke that we had.
NASA has a big problem with
data, but not a big data
problem.
For the whole Space
Shuttle program,
we had about 980,000
problem reports.
And problem reports
are really important.
It's the history.
It's what tells you
what risks you have.
It helps you understand
the fact that you've
got risk coming forward.
And 980,000 is very little.
It's too much for any
person to have in mind.
But it's not enough
to really give you
any kind of power in the way
that, for example, Google
search yields, answers
the way it does because
of the combination of big data
plus understanding what humans
have looked at.
But big data, at the same
time, is remarkably powerful.
And this has been one of the
big source of transformation,
it yields just associations
and your data falls out.
So this was one of the
early Google deep learning
experiments, where they looked
at still images from YouTube
and these three things fell out.
So there was like a face.
These were like when you
looked at the kind of averages
that the algorithm
came up with, there
was a face, a blobby
thing that was maybe
a human detector,
and then a cat,
because I guess there
are a lot of cat videos.
And the important
thing is, again, I
want to contrast this with
what I was saying before.
So this is what you get when you
look at millions and millions
and millions of things.
And then you get these averages.
And babies detect
faces at birth.
Babies will focus
on a face at birth.
And there are studies
that show that pigeons
will recognize human faces.
And not just human faces,
specific human faces.
OK so not just humans with
our big brains, but even birds
with their little brain.
And again, we're born that way.
And so as you kind
of raise this up,
and you say, well,
what are the--
So a little more here on
kind of the deep learning
for pattern recognition.
So if I look up a
picture like this.
And I say show me
other pictures like it,
and it shows me other pictures
like it, you sort of say, boy,
that seems intelligent.
But the key point
is that this is
being arrived at in a very
different way than humans.
And the consequence of that
is that if you think about it,
for certain kinds of problems,
you still want that kind
of adaptive, inductive,
humans problem solving .
So here, I go a little
bit more into this point.
So humans are very
much about causation.
Intelligence
systems are really--
and have continued to
be-- about correlation.
And by the way, I'm not
making any of this up.
I mean this is like
when I was at Carnegie
Mellon in the '90s, working
AI, what we were working on
was trying to get
causal reasoning out
of intelligent systems, It
just hasn't really progressed.
It's been hard.
The real progress,
as I said, has come
from big data and Moore's law.
And again, I think
that internet of things
is going to be the
other big changer.
The reason this is interesting
is because the minute something
knows itself what it is.
So this thing, in some way,
it knows it's Alonzo's phone,
and can even tell
you where it is.
And something can ping it and
say, are you Alonzo's phone?
Yes, I am.
My pen, at some point,
might know that it's my pen.
And it'll know where it is.
It might even know
it's being held.
it's being held by me.
That is all going to
come very quickly.
And that begins to
change our ability
to interact with the world.
Because suddenly like
the things in the world--
you begin to solve some of
that kind of old AI grounding
problem, this way.
So humans, you know, what
we're good at, again,
is solving in a slow
way, like hours today
is complex problems
under uncertaintly.
And machines tend to
be just the opposite--
very fast, but problems
that are well determined.
And so you get a real synergy.
And if done right, machine
intelligence actually
fills exactly the gaps
that humans are bad at
and vice versa.
This is from the
Department of Defense.
It was just interesting
to me to go look
at what their
investment profile is.
This little blue side is human
and autonomous interaction
and collaboration.
So 50% of the investment the
Department of Defense has
is on the human autonomy team.
And I actually think that
what's going to happen over
the next 15 to 20 years is that
those companies that are aware,
really, that you don't
want to end up with things
like the littoral
combat ship and that
invest in understanding,
how do we pair humans
with intelligent systems,
especially when you've
got a need for those
humans because you
need the problem solving, you
need the adaptive reasoning.
I think that that's
where you're going
to see the next generation of
companies that push forward.
And in some ways, I think
it's one view of maybe what
Steve Jobs was doing at Apple.
I mean he kept that company
entirely focused on, what
does the end user need to
see, what is that interaction,
and developed a unique
set of products.
It's a broad statement.
But I think it was
part of what he really
brought to bear in a way that
other companies struggled
to do-- and I'm talking here
about like say mobile phone
companies or whatever--
How do I integrate this
with human experience so
you're not even really
aware that this
thing is actually
sort of working with you.
In fact, I have an
example from-- so remember
when there was a fallout
between Apple and Google?
And Google Maps wasn't
on the latest version?
And then it reappeared.
So my wife said, I'm
trying to find this place.
And I said, No.
Install Google Maps.
It's much better.
And so she did.
And then she entered her thing.
And she said, how
do I tell it to go?
And I said, well, you don't.
It knows when you're starting.
It's not playing a
little routine for you.
It's interacting and knows--
And so she was like, oh yeah.
And so it was a bit
of a conceptual shift.
The funny thing is, she
walked out of the kitchen
and started walking
down the hall.
And it said, turn left
at North Springer Road.
So it's good.
But they're not great, yet.
There's a certain larger
context which they lack.
Similarly is a break
down that I had.
A little company in the
Valley called Venture Scanner.
And I had them look
at AI investments.
This is an industry.
And this is sort of
like current investment
in artificial intelligence
of venture capital.
And you look at the
blue and the red
are sort of the
collaborative versus green
is what you call
narrow autonomy.
So, for example, here,
you get deep learning,
machine learning-- tends to
be not worried about how it's
going to interact with humans.
Other areas like
natural language--
obviously a lot of blue.
But you look overall, and
it's about the same pattern.
About half the
investment right now
is going into human
autonomy teaming.
So final thoughts.
I think robotics will continue
to progress faster than AI.
Humans will very likely
remain important components
of complex systems.
And I hope I've convinced
you a little bit, again,
that in this hour that the
way our brains are shaped
by evolution, and the
way that we think,
and the way we learn
about the world
is very much determined,
again, by evolution,
by natural selection, by
what allowed us to survive.
And so we are a certain kind of
learning, thinking, reasoning
machine.
We're not a general
kind of-- And with
that comes certain benefits.
Machines are a very different
kind of learning system,
right now.
We haven't actually
really made progress
in trying to simulate
the human one.
It's unclear that we want to.
But what I think we do want
to is increasingly pair those.
And that's something that at the
moment, we don't do very well.
And it costs us.
So use human adaptive
expertise as much as possible.
Use the human perceptual system
as much as possible-- that idea
like in the Mercedes-Benz
cars and with the flowlines.
And then be aware in some areas,
when you don't have big data.
Because not all problems
are associated in nature.
And that's probably,
more often than not,
when you actually
still need humans.
So those are my last thoughts.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Where are
we in terms of using
the brain as a model for AI?
Like whereabouts are
we in that research?
ALONSO VERA: Because
our understanding
of the brain at this point
is really so rudimentary,
it's much less advanced
than you'd think.
So a few years ago,
there was a project--
and this is maybe five
years ago now, funded
by DARPA called--
what was it called--
I think it was called
the Brain Initiative.
We knew people who were on that.
They really went and took
the top computational
cognitive modeling
people, neuroscientists
from every university.
The top ones.
That first meeting
had about 60 people.
And they were really the
top people in the country.
And everybody sat in that room.
And this is sort of the
way DARPA does things.
But the goal was,
in two years, we
want to have a functional
model brain kinda thing.
Everybody in that room said
like, we're 100 years off that,
as far as I know.
So now there could be some
transformational, some quantum
leap that happens--
something that changes
the way we look at this.
But it hasn't happened yet.
And again, as I said
before, most people
think that the real
challenge at this point
is we don't have the math.
So people say what we need
is the Newton for brain.
Somebody comes up
and says, you're
not gonna solve these problems
until you have calculus.
because for this kind of
complex dynamic systems,
that's the problem.
Computationally, with even
our current computer power,
you can't simulate
anything close to it.
And really the most fundamental
thing is we barely understand.
So we know, for example,
that the visual cortex,
area 17 of the brain,
which is back here,
actually has maps-- like
actual representations of what
I'm seeing and that there
are neurons that detect lines
and that detect crossing
of lines and movement.
So we understand
some of those things,
and to some extent,
areas of the brain, etc.
But the brain as
a dynamic system
that's processing information
and using that it's really
not well understood yet.
AUDIENCE: So you talked
quite a bit about evolution
and how the human
brain has evolved
to solve certain problems.
And then you made a
claim late in the talk
that basically people are
bad at quickly processing
large datasets reliably.
So vision is sort of the
counterargument to that, right?
So the visual system
is specialized,
as you pointed out, to
process a large volume of data
very quickly and very reliably.
So is that the case, perhaps,
that because of the way
we've evolved, we just
have certain big data
problems that the human brain
is capable of effectively
and quickly processing.
Whereas a simulated system
could be a generalized learning
machine, could bring that, sort
of-- if we could understand
a compositional apparatus
to bear on any problem
rather than just those that were
evolutionarily advantageous?
So do you have any
comments on that?
ALONSO VERA: Yeah.
No, that's a really good point.
I actually hadn't
thought of that,
that a lot of what we do-- like
what the visual system does,
what our mobility systems do.
So I mean take another example.
So walking robots, biped robots
has been a very difficult
thing, right?
And yet babies are walking
in less than a year.
And so a lot of the--
And you're right.
Those are, in a sense,
they are big data problems.
It's just we're
pre-wired to do those.
So the things that are the
big data problems like fusion
of visual information, we seem
to have a lot of preparedness
for.
Yeah.
So maybe then the
argument becomes
that the part of the
human brain which
is sort of the higher level
information processing,
problem solving, that it's
that part that doesn't function
on big data.
But yeah, the basic
perceptual system does.
Yeah Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]